Nicholas earring needs to leave earlier
now that Denmark has reinstated border
controls every day he drives 10
kilometers to the Danish border earrings
commute to his workplace in Denmark now
takes longer isn't an especially tense
Lagoon well this is a special border
region the city of Flint's Berg is
comprised of some thirty percent Danish
residents we've always worked well
together and suddenly we've got order
checks spits what's there hard for
people living and working in this area
and should be abolished again quickly
again yerens car is checked on his way
to work come on the border official
doesn't want to be filmed after a quick
check yelling is free to go
but for many others this is the end of
the road a bus is checked this Afghan
family of eight wanted to travel through
Denmark to Sweden but the Danish police
won't let them continue their journey
now they must decide either they return
to Germany or apply for asylum in
Denmark but the odds of being granted
asylum here are slim Denmark has some of
the strictest immigration policies in
all of Europe and now passport checks
have been introduced to stem the flow
the Danish town of zineb or lies just a
few kilometers from the German border
700 Syrian refugees live here in a
former army barracks
Achmed Kutta applied for asylum six
months ago he and his fellow refugees
know it's a long process I don't think
about my future if they are good of like
many use every two months three months
in Euros how I can't think about my
future that I cannot imagine my future
how it would be even if Ahmed is granted
asylum he will have to wait three years
until his family can join him
Danish right-wing populists had pushed
through border checks and less money for
Refugees me vision yar
we know that there are three hundred
thousand refugees on the German border
who haven't applied for asylum they want
to go to Sweden they'll need to cross
Denmark and they may want to stay here
so we control our borders we can't take
everyone in that's reality loiter here
sooner Bohr's mayor disagrees he says
his town has benefited culturally and
economically from the open border the
social democrat sees border controls as
a threat to his country Denmark with
armor five years in Denmark will become
poorer we're a small country we need to
cooperate that we can't shut ourselves
in and protect our prosperity Ansley's
not front Anton wouldn't and happen
many see a connection between the fate
of the refugees and the future of Europe
which is why Nicola searing supports
refugees in Flensburg the Afghan who
tried crossing into Denmark this morning
is here as well
he says his entire family is in Sweden
he said that he's not able to join them
so cancer whooping Musa Susanne my
Europe has to work together but we're
not doing that right now water controls
main Europe has failed these are people
who aren't allowed to join their
families because they lack the necessary
papers a disagreement between
neighboring states in Europe as Denmark
seals its borders Germany upholds the
Schengen Agreement Nikolas sharing
supports this otherwise it wouldn't make
sense for him to commute to work in
Denmark
you